tous les quotidiens français aujourd'hui
affiche vous allez le voir une pleine
page de publicité pour le guide michelin
pourquoi alors que le guide est sorti il
ya plus d'un mois maintenant et bien
parce qu'il a été contestée pour la
première fois sérieusement par l'un de
ses anciens inspecteurs affirmant que
michelin n'avait pas les moyens en
hommes pour visiter tous les restaurants
indiqué dans le guide estimant par
ailleurs que certains trois étoiles ne
méritait pas forcément un tel honneur
alors un mois après ces affirmations
le guide se venge à sa façon et on sait
que la vengeance est un plat qui se
mange froid
crespy deux ans d'existence et déjà une
étoile au michelin l'an dernier pour ce
restaurant étoilé les deux chefs de
cuisine ont rapidement senti les
retombées économiques immédiates mais
figurer dans le guide
c'est bien plus que cela vient de vous
voir ah ça c'est pour nous c'est énorme
quand on vous parle des toiles l'étoile
c'est c'est le graal passe et c'est
vraiment même pour tous les
restaurateurs la personne le
restaurateur qui me dit que ça n'a pas
d'importance et vous mentirais
car le guide michelin est une véritable
institution mais ces inspecteurs et
leurs pratiques sont aujourd'hui
controversé après saison chez michelin
avec ce livre cet ancien inspecteur sur
la table il faut absolument que le
lecteur redevienne au centre des
priorités des gens qui font guide et il
faut absolument que ça passe avant le le
le côté marketing et financier sur
l'effectif des inspecteurs en exercice
sur la moyenne des visites dans les
restaurants sur les liens privilégiés
avec les grands chefs le directeur dudit
dément qu'il a parlé d des tables
intouchable il n'y a pas de sens dans
cette danse est propos parce que le
guide c'est un guide fait pour le client
et le client si on avait des
recommandations dont le guide qui était
pas ce que l'on trouve le client sur
place il va nous dire tout de suite le
clion lui vient chercher la qualité et
les étoiles sont toujours la référence
en cuisine comme en salle